[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Wednesday April 12th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
a group of women who say social media
devastated their sons and daughters
lives is pushing Congress to pass new
laws that would force platforms to do
more to protect miners call it Mom power
but Silicon Valley Tech firms have for
years been able to push back efforts to
make them more accountable so will the
efforts of parents make things different
our Tech policy reporter Ryan Tracy
joins us now to discuss that hi Ryan
thanks for being here thank you let's
start with these mothers who are they
and why have they taken on this fight
these are women who experienced really
tragedies in their lives that they blame
in part on social media so one of the
leaders for example had a 16 year old
son who died by suicide after being
Cyber Bullied are the ones had children
who attempted a Blackout Challenge and
passed away you know drugs online you
name the online arm these women have
experienced it in some way and that
motivated them to get active to press
for social media regulations that in
their view would prevent these kind of
things from happening to other children
and other families so what type of
legislation are they pushing for because
there have been a number of bills that
have circulated in Congress over the
past few years yeah and you know that's
been one of the issues with trying to
get the Congress to adopt Tech policy is
that there have just been so many ideas
and not a lot of consensus about which
one to focus on kids targeted
legislation is an area where you would
think there would be 60 votes in the
Senate right a lot of support for
something like that the specific bill
that these mothers want is called the
kids online safety act it was introduced
last year and a new version is going to
be introduced soon what that would do is
say to any company that's got a digital
product that is likely to be used by
children hey before before you put this
out there you need to be doing some
assessment of what kind of harms could
happen to Young users and take some
steps to mitigate or prevent those harms
now the tech companies have a host of
problems with that but you know that's
the basic structure and there are other
things in the build too do they have a
specific list of actions that they want
tech companies to take each of them has
as part of Their Own Story something
specific that they might want so for
example one of the mothers whose son was
Cyber Bullied was really concerned about
anonymous messages being sent on social
media apps because that was something
that happened to her son and the
legislation is written in a broader
sense you know it doesn't give the tech
platforms here's a 10-point checklist
that you have to do it it says here are
some of the things you need to consider
for example whether features are
addictive or whether they could lead to
mental health issues and leaving it
open-ended so that if new products are
invented that we don't foresee that it
would still apply to those two what are
the tech companies saying about the
these specific bills and the efforts
that are coming now from parents to push
them through so the tech companies would
say that if you add that kind of
potential liability to an app developer
or a company putting even just a website
out there that kids could find you could
really have some unintended consequences
one potential thing that could happen
for example is companies could be a lot
more aggressive in moderating the
content on their site because if there's
a piece of content out there that causes
harm and they could be held accountable
for that well then they might want to
make sure that they really over correct
and don't have anything that could be
construed as harmful you know and there
are some transgender groups for example
who are concerned that Tech platforms
could be pressured to treat any content
related to transgender issues as harmful
but the moms say that a lot of these
concerns are overblown and they're
having these meetings on Capitol Hill
they're working in state houses to
advance proposals like this and you know
they're really having an effect I mean
these are powerful meetings when mothers
come in and talk about these tragedies
which lawmakers are they targeting well
there are a subset of lawmakers who are
interested in this issue but may not
believe that these particular proposals
are the right one or may not necessarily
want to prioritize them and one of the
meetings I came across was with Senator
Maria Cantwell last November Senator
Cantwell is the chair of the Senate
Commerce Committee so she's a very
powerful person and she you know was
broadly supportive of this legislation
but hadn't really thrown her full weight
behind it and these moms were trying to
get a meeting with her they weren't able
to so they walked into her office one
morning holding pictures of their dead
children whose deaths they blamed on
social media you can imagine what the
staff members of the senator how wide
Their Eyes Were when that happened and
so these moms got their meeting they
talked with her for about an hour and lo
and behold later that afternoon she was
saying we need to move this legislation
urgently which was a shift for her she
hadn't been saying that that she wanted
to pass it before the end of last year
now look it didn't ultimately pass but
it shows that these mothers are kind of
an important Force here and that they're
one that the tech companies are going to
have to start paying attention to and
Reckoning with two other Senators who
have sort of been at the Forefront of
pushing through legislation to rein in
the power of big Tech are Richard
Blumenthal from Connecticut and Marcia
Blackburn from Tennessee are they
involved at all with these mothers yeah
in fact they're coordinating very
closely those two senators are these
main sponsors of this kids online safety
act that the the mother's favor along
with some other advocacy groups and when
the mothers came to meet those Senators
you know they were preaching to the
choir right these are people who are
already on their side but it was a
fairly organized effort last year when
that meeting happened they invited
reporters into the room they had cameras
there and that showed some organization
Behind These mothers you know this isn't
quite Mothers Against Drunk Driving yet
but it is a new thing in the tech policy
space to have mothers organizing like
this so what's next for these moms well
they're looking both at the state and
federal level to try to move these bills
forward and there's a new version of the
federal legislation that's going to be
introduced in the coming weeks and one
big question is the House of
Representatives where lawmakers do want
to protect children obviously but they
also are still in favor of passing a
broader privacy bill that would apply to
everyone so there's a bit of a strategic
difference between the two Chambers
about how to proceed here and that's
going to be one hurdle to overcome as
well all right that's wsj Tech policy
reporter Ryan Tracy
thank you Zoe
that's it for today
s briefing for more Tech stories head
over to our website wsj.com I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]